i think life is really tough for working
parents but especially working mums who
are bearing the brunt of it and
especially people with
kids under 10 what we're hearing is that
even with kids going back to school
nurseries are still struggling some are
putting caps on numbers
uh breakfast clubs for older children
after school
clubs aren't necessarily up and running
and of course that
whole network that working parents rely
on
of mates and grandparents and child
minders
is under real pressure so i think there
are an awful lot of
working mums out there who are feeling
really stressed right now
it's interesting isn't it because i
guess lots of people think well
nurseries are reopened schools are
reopened what's the problem but it's
almost a real
kind of patchwork of support that so
many working parents
rely on whether it's grandparents or
after school clubs
that simply isn't there at the minute
well you pull one thread and the worry
is that
everything unravels and what we're
seeing is
you know even where people can work at
home it's very often the case that it's
uh the working mother who's taking on
the
big responsibility for children and
having kids around your feet and trying
to do a job isn't easy
and some of the choices that women are
being forced to make
include cutting their hours of work or
going in really early or ending up doing
effectively an evening shift to try and
keep on top of their jobs so
i think a lot of working women in
particular are desperate for some more
flexibility
but also desperate to see the government
take child care seriously
and provide some support especially for
the nursery sector
it's interesting to hear you talk though
about how working
mothers in particular are bearing the
brunt of course you know lots of dads
are spending lots of time
uh with child care responsibilities too
but studies by the
institute for fiscal studies and others
have seemed to suggest it's mainly women
picking up
quite a lot of the burden what does this
mean for women's
job prospects well i i think the risk
here is that we see
attitudes and behaviors setting women
back decades you know we've made a lot
of progress
in terms of equal pay respect for women
a recognition that you know women want
to get on at work
as much as men but when women are
picking up
the lion's share of the burden not just
of childcare but it looks like housework
too
that makes life difficult and it it's
exposed just how fragile
and underfunded our child care system is
and
you know i i think the government needs
to understand
that we need working patterns that work
for parents and especially working moms
as much as anybody else there's got to
be two-way flexibility we'd like to see
a right
to flexible working from day one
and you talk there a little bit about
this but what do you think the
government needs to do
right now to try and help working
parents get back to the office as it
says it wants to
well all our work has shown that we've
still got lots of nurseries
that are on the brink of collapse many
have had no choice but to cap numbers
and that questions whether they're
financially viable
over this coronavirus period and as i
said before
a lot of the informal care that working
parents rely on
has unraveled child minders families you
know it's much
more difficult so i think we need you
know
if anybody's going to get a bail out the
child care sector deserves a bear out
because that's crucial for the economy
that
allows working parents to do their job
so it would be a
force economy not to give proper support
to childcare
but i think we also need to see progress
on two other fronts you know there needs
to be that right to flexible working
where we can make it work with the
business let's have two-way flexibility
because i can tell you as you probably
know all too well
that when you're doing long hours and a
precious job
having that bit more flexibility can
make all the difference so let's have
that right to flexible working and a bit
more compassion
on that front but i also think we've got
to make progress on equal pay
uh you know we're not there yet we've
still got a way to go
before women get equal pay for work of
equal value
and as long as there's unequal pay then
it feels like women are always going to
end up picking up the pieces when
there's a child's care problem
because in the end they're not often
on average earning as much as their
partner so we've got to see action on
that front too